[Music]
so I've spent some time trying to
understand this iPad I I've never been
so confused by so many choices in one
new product so this is the new 10th
Generation Baseline iPad and it's in one
of those bright new colors too and this
thing has a slightly new design which is
overall improved the home button is gone
it's a pretty familiar rectangular shape
now with flatter sides the new colors
are actually kinda saturated which is
neat this one here is yellow but there's
also a pink and a blue on top of the
safe bet silver it's slightly less
saturated than it looks on Apple's
website though there's a touch ID button
up top so you do get biometric unlocking
even though there's no home button
thinner bezels thinner anyway and a
slightly larger 11 inch LCD screen up
front landscape stereo speakers a bump
from an 8 to a 12 megapixel camera on
the back and an A14 bionic chip inside
not their newest but it's a step up from
the a13 bionic that's in the 9th gen
iPad so none of that is confusing
they're modernizing the Baseline iPad
great but then that's that's where some
of the weirdness starts so first of all
upgrades to USB type c
finally now it's not Thunderbolt speeds
or anything but hey you can now finally
plug in USBC flash drives you can charge
fast you can even plug in an external
display up to 4K 30 Hertz or 1080p 60hz
which you were definitely not doing with
the lightning Port before I had been
asking for USBC getting it in the base
iPad now is great it's confusing though
because they also announced that this
iPad will support
the first generation apple pencil
which if you remember uh it's it's
lightning this was the pencil that
infamously hilariously plugged into the
bottom of the old iPads to charge via
that lightning Port but if we're USBC
now then that means oh god oh no it's
it's happening this needs a USBC to
lightning adapter to charge the pencil
I'm sure no one will ever lose this it
also comes in this separate piece of
packaging it doesn't come in the iPad
box or in the apple pencil box it's more
packaging which is a little more
wasteful but also yeah if you ever do
lose it and need another one nine bucks
but I'm still just thinking like apple
you made a new pencil a second gen
pencil that's way better the second
generation pencil snaps onto the side of
the iPad Air or the iPad Pro with
magnets and charges wirelessly where is
that one here I feel like I've been
through every version of this in my head
but basically what I've come up with is
some people would probably say that
Apple knows that there are going to be
groups of people businesses schools that
have the older ninth generation iPad and
they have pencils and they're going to
want to continue using those pencils
when they upgrade to this new iPad
that's why they kept support for the old
apple pencil
and to those people I would say
but you make both por que no Los Dos why
not both so honestly the real answer is
most likely because this is the first
ever iPad to move the webcam to that
long side the long bezel low-key that
might be the best change in this whole
piece of Hardware so now when you're on
video calls or doing anything while
looking at the camera it'll actually
look like you're looking at the camera
instead of way off to the side like in
every other iPad so this is a welcome
change but now that means the spot that
you'd normally slap on the second
generation apple pencil with magnets and
a cutout well that's now populated by
webcam housing and the other side has
the smart pins which I'll get to in a
second and then the top and the bottom
are speakers and apparently it would be
two on Apple like to put it like off to
the side you know asymmetrical like that
or something just to just to have space
for the cutouts basically Apple also
came out with their new M2 iPad Pro at
the same time as this that also has a 12
megapixel Ultra wide webcam with Center
Stage just like this one but it's not
moved to the long side it's still on
that side spot which leads me to believe
that Apple views this as a direct
compromise you can either have the new
Apple pencil and that'll charge at the
top or you can have the webcam on the
long side one or the other but not both
and I guess we'll never see an iPad Pro
with the webcam in the right spot so for
those who want a little bit more out of
the Baseline iPad Apple has also dropped
a brand new completely redesigned
two-piece magic keyboard folio for the
iPad I actually really like most of it
this first piece is just like a back
plate that attaches to the iPad with
magnets and then acts as just a
kickstand basically very surface very
useful and then with the second piece
it's just a new keyboard with a new Full
function row up at the top so now that
the SMART connector pins are on the side
edge instead of the back you can just
slap on or remove the keyboard at any
time and just go straight to the iPad so
this two-piece setup has its benefits
and drawbacks the main drawback really
being that it's not as laughable it's
much more suited for working on desk or
a more stable surface because of the
weight distribution but the benefit is
it's two pieces it's modular so now you
can just go straight kickstand if you
want to just watch a movie or a show
with no hands or you can add a keyboard
anytime you want to type or if you want
if you want to be mobile but take the
keyboard with you you can flip the
keyboard around so that you're not
feeling those buttons on the back all
the time every time you're holding the
thing so that's nice I like the idea but
there are still a couple head scratchers
first of all uh this new two-piece setup
is not coming to the new iPad Pro for
some reason I would think if you like
those function keys that you'd want that
for the iPad Pro but this is only for
this iPad but then also this iPad does
not get stage manager not that stage
manager is you know that amazing or
anything but this would have been nice
for people who want to use that USBC
plug it into an external Monitor and get
a little bit more window management a
little bit more of that multitasking
going on but this one won't do that
weird but then the biggest head
scratcher of them all has got to be the
prices right so this is still a 250
dollar keyboard and case accessory and
then this new iPad here is starting at
four hundred and fifty dollars which is
a pretty big price bump from the 9th gen
iPad we just upgraded from which stays
in Apple's lineup at 330 unchanged
this might be kind of a hot take but I
don't really understand why this one
exists like I'm not even saying it's a
bad product it's a perfectly good iPad
it works it does all the things it's got
the new chip it's got the little things
it's got Wi-Fi six now it's got a
perfectly fine display it's got USBC the
new colors it's thin it's a tablet it's
it's fine I just it's weird like if you
just want a basic iPad this person still
exists right oh I just want to get a
basic iPad that's the schools the
businesses that's the moms getting it to
like put it in a giant foam case and
like hand it to their kid to watch
videos like I just I just need an iPad
that's still the 329 9th gen iPad it's a
hundred something dollars cheaper it's a
better deal that's still the one I would
recommend for those people but then the
second you think like oh I might want a
little bit more from my iPad I want to
do a little more right maybe I want to
like use it as a pseudo computer a
little bit the second you think oh I
want it to be a real computer this this
is 64 gigs at the Baseline in 2022 not
real computer storage so you bump up to
real computer storage and then this plus
this is
850 dollars
what
what I mean you could get an iPad Air
for that price you could get an iPad Pro
for that price you could also just get a
computer for that price so this is a
strange combination of things to exist
together for that amount of money like
even without the keyboard this iPad 64
gigs in 2022 for 450 dollars is just
it's just weird so in conclusion
this is a slightly strange set of stuff
slotted between sweet and simple
sufficient for some but pretty silly for
most
thanks for watching